okay you can participate in uh
respectful political discussions
on the david pakman show subreddit at
davidpakman.com
r-e-d-d-i-t a few interesting posts i
spotted this morning
there is a new poll which um
indicates that 50 of americans
believe joe biden is too liberal
what i think is really interesting about
this
uh is that you right now have
completely opposite claims being made
about joe biden
the right every day this week at the
republican national convention has been
insisting that if joe biden wins
he will affect his socialist marxist
ideology on the country
and we won't have capitalism and right
you understand the way that that goes
the progressive left meanwhile is
displeased that joe biden is not really
very left
now what's the truth there is some
empirical reality here and the empirical
reality is
that joe biden generally speaking is a
center-left candidate
who as a sign of the times because it's
2020
and not 2012 or 2008 or 1993
as some people like to point to when
they talk about joe biden's beliefs
joe biden has adopted elements
of what bernie sanders wants on climate
and the economy of what aoc would like
to see
in the green new deal and so in the
broader global context if you have put
biden on a political spectrum that
includes europe for example
biden is center-left-ish and if you
compare
biden's platforms to those of previous
american presidents
he is the most progressive on a bunch of
issues
but that doesn't mean that much when you
compare him to people like hillary
clinton
and barack obama etc that's the reality
somehow half the country
thinks biden is too far left that tells
you a little bit about how the united
states compares politically to many
other parts of the world
user karaoke 23 asked
after posting some videos of some
protests how are these people going to
react
if trump loses i am going to address
this in detail on tomorrow's program and
i'm going to look at
which electoral scenario in november is
the most likely to lead to violence
and who is likely to be doing the
violence i don't believe it's hyperbolic
to be thinking about it i don't believe
it's hyperbolic to be concerned about it
i think there is a real possibility for
violence and listen
i'm going to be talking about kyle
rittenhouse the 17 year old who started
shooting people
in wisconsin okay the violence is
already happening and i think it's quite
possible donald trump will weaponize and
coalesce
um that more of that violence depending
on the results
lastly user knife edger asks
is jimmy from philly for real i just
listened to the segment on david's
youtube channel
until recently i genuinely thought this
was a real guy with real delusions
but segments like this make me wonder is
this a character i'm new here but i'm
sure this question
gets asked all the time on this um
subreddit
i am here to tell you jimmy from philly
is very real
it is not a character that he is playing
and i know that we often wonder
sometimes people are so out there that
it's a natural question to say is this a
character how can someone like this even
get through the day how can someone like
this survive into adulthood quite
frankly
but jimmy from philly is real he is a
trumpist he is a furious trumpist
and um there is every indication
that he is completely genuine in the
beliefs he espouses and that's a very
scary thing because as i said before
even if trump loses in november we will
still have
more than 60 million people who will
have voted for trump and that's
something we will have to deal with
join the discussion at davidpakman.com
reddit more than uh 20 000 of you have
subscribed
over on reddit making us one of the
largest progressive media
subreddits on the internet an incredible
accolade
if you love feeding your intellectual
curiosity but you're always
struggling to find the time check out
one of my all-time
favorite apps called blinkist blinkist
lets you consume an
entire book on your way home from work
they take
thousands of popular nonfiction books
condense each one
into text or audio that you can get
through in just 15 minutes and you get
all of the important
core ideas and information from that
book it's perfect
if you don't have enough time to do all
the reading you want to do
or if you just want to sample a book
before you buy the entire thing
i recently read a brief history of time
of course by the great
stephen hawking this is a book that i
have been aware of for so long and
other things got in the way and it was
fantastic
to check it out on blinkist blinkist has
books on politics philosophy science
they have 27 different non-fiction
categories and a subscription
is only about eight bucks a month and
you get the entire
library but you can try it totally free
and get twenty five percent off a
subscription when you go to blinkist.com
pacman i've put the link right
underneath this video